dans l'actualité ce soir des villes
entières raser un bilan de 50 à 80 mille
morts et disparus la chine revoit à la
hausse les conséquences du séisme
cent mille soldats et policiers sont
déployés sur les lieux serrer les coudes
et dédramatiser les députés ump veulent
d'afficher la cohésion après leur rapt
et de la loi ogm une ovation a été
réservé à jean françois copé à françois
fillon qui évoque un incident
regrettable
le ton monte à la veille d'une journée
de grève dans la fonction publique et
notamment à l'école deux fédérations de
parents d'élèves estiment que les
enfants sont instrumentalisée à des fins
politiques
le mouvement s'annonce suivi l'inflation
n'augmente plus mais reste à un niveau
élevé 0 3% au mois d'avril 3% sur un an
démonstration par l'exemple ce soir
l'envolée du prix de la fraise française
la retraite en pleine gloire justine
henin à la numéro un mondiale du tennis
féminin annonce qu'elle met fin à sa
carrière pour cause de défaut de
motivation
enfin 22 films pour une palme le
festival de cannes a commencé avec la
première montée des marches pour sean
penn et les autres membres du jury deux
invités de marque ce soir angelina jolie
et dustin hoffman réunis pour un film
inattendu rendez vous à la fin de ce
journal
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous la situation
est pire que ce qu'on craignait
c'est un responsable chinois qu'il
affirme alors que parviennent peu à peu
des informations en provenance des zones
les plus reculées
avant toute chose je vous propose de
découvrir ces images qui nous sont
parvenus aujourd'hui tourné au moment
même du séisme dans une zone
heureusement peu urbanisée philippe
rochot
que faire
la poussière et la panique c'est le
tremblement de terre du sichuan tel que
l'a vécu un terroriste qui montait au
montini chan à 50 km de l'épicentre du
séisme
il faut sortir de là l'homme veut fuir
l'endroit mais il a le courage de
continuer à filmer pendant les deux
minutes interminables que va durer la
secousse merde c'est bloqué doucement
doucement
voilà c'est bon là
dans le village les habitants sont
blessés sous le choc les bâtiments de
briques n'ont pas résisté
mais notre témoin a la chance de se
trouver dans une zone guerre urbanisé il
y aura plus de victimes
ce genre de scène s'est produite dans
des milliers de villages comme celui ci
pendant ce tremblement de terre du
sichuan
je vous le disais on commence tout juste
à avoir un aperçu de la situation dans
les montagnes et les informations sont
alarmantes des villes entières seraient
rasées ailleurs dans les très grandes
agglomérations les militaires et les
policiers sont à l'oeuvre
la pluie a cessé aujourd'hui et de
nouveaux survivants étaient dégagés des
décombres
shiro moderne là dessous il y aurait
encore 900 élèves 60 heures qu'ils sont
prisonniers de leur collège effondré en
quelques secondes les chances de survie
sont minimes
les parents attendent l'arrivée d'un
corps celui d'un enfant
le fils de cette femme
des milliers de familles anéanties
elles ont perdu leur enfant unique le
plus souvent conséquence du contrôle des
naissances en chine
l'avancée des secours et parfois
perturbé par des répliques il y en a des
dizaines par jour hutin et parfois
quelques cours mon bonheur
comme ce matin à 12 jeunes jambes
un petit miracle un double miracle eux
mêmes cette jeune femme est enceinte de
huit mois
elle et son bébé sont sains et saufs
mais dans ces camps de fortune on a
désormais plus habitude de voir ça les
feux d'artifice en hommage à une
nouvelle dépouille un rite pour éloigner
les fantômes pour les survivants
la priorité c'est la nourriture dans
certaines zones
l'aide arrive à peine il n'y en a pas
pour tout le monde malheur aux plus
faibles comme cette femme elle n'a pas
mangé depuis trois jours à manger quoi
il n'y a rien à manger lucelle de la
rivière est polluée dans l'armée cent
mille soldats déployés progressent
péniblement vers wayne swan la zone de
l'épicentre où ils ne savent pas encore
ce qui les fait se sont parfois même les
blessés qui viennent à eux
ici il n'ya plus de route plus de ponts
c'est donc par canaux qu'ils avancent la
météo permet enfin aux hélicoptères de
décoller et au premier ministre arrivé à
wayne swan
gloria le gouvernement dit il ne vous
oubliera pas depuis le séisme il a
arpenté toute la région jusqu'à celle de
l'épicentre
en voici les premières images une zone
totalement coupés du monde
jusqu'à ce matin jusqu'à ce qu'un
premier groupe de soldats d'élite il
soit parachuté avec des vivres nos
envoyés spéciaux samah soula et tristan
le brazon au passé une partie de la
journée aux côtés des sinistrés dix
mille personnes sans maison sans
ressources
entassés dans un stade et qui attendent
de l'aide
voici le reportage ci paysans descente
juste de leur montagne dévasté hagard
épuisé par la peur et la longue marche
sur les pentes escarpées la zone de
mianyang compterait plus de 3000 morts
et vingt mille personnes toujours
ensevelies
depuis 48 heures ils arrivent par
grappes au stade du dew l'arche des
survivants dix mille personnes s'y
entassent déjà ce qui frappe avant tout
c'est la présence des enfants
ils ont échappé au pire on les entoure
de toutes les attentions tant d'autres
manquent à l'appel dans chaque coin des
larmes de désespoir la détresse est
partout je n'ai plus de famille ma mère
mon frère ma belle-soeur plus personne
attendez vous
avi
il ya beaucoup de vieillards et
d'enfants encore coincés sous les
décombres
certains sont encore vivants mais les
secours n'arrivent pas ils sont en train
de mourir on est très inquiet le ring de
boxe a été transformée en camp de
fortune un semblant d'intimité dans la
promiscuité total une distraction
inespéré pour ce gamin qui a déjà une
gueule de boxeur chaque arrivée de
sucreries provoque la même précipitation
de la nourriture et des vêtements
distribués par les bénévoles en silence
certains errent dans les travées munis
de pancartes portant le nom d'un parent
dont ils sont sans nouvelles
cette femme recherche son neveu elle
donne des détails à qui veut bien
l'écouter depuis le séisme
je n'arrive plus à joindre personne dans
mon village personne
l'immense solitude du rescapé malgré les
gestes de réconfort modeste et discret à
porter parce qu'ils n'ont pas tout perdu
non
des milliers de réfugiés continuent
d'affluer dans ce stade des rescapés
mais après avoir survécu il leur faut
affronter la mort de leurs proches des
centaines de familles décimées et je
peux vous dire que nous assistons ici à
des tels des sciences une image encore
je vous le disais hier la flamme
olympique poursuit son périple en chine
mais le coeur n'est pas vraiment à la
fête évidemment une minute de silence a
été observée au départ du relais la
flamme qui doit traverser cette région
du sichuan la région la plus touchée par
le séisme
le mois prochain une image aussi de
birmanie où l'onu est parvenu à ouvrir
une plateforme logistique dans la plus
grande ville du delta dévastée par le
cyclone on est très loin toutefois d'une
réponse appropriée aux besoins de la
population
nous avons reçu aujourd'hui ces images
de jeunes enfants recueillis dans un
monastère
le commissaire européen au développement
louis michel qui a obtenu son visa
évoque un risque de famine en raison de
la destruction de tous les stocks de riz
dans cette même région du delta
l'actualité en france ambiance survoltée
aujourd'hui encore à l'assemblée
nationale après le camouflet infligé au
gouvernement et à nicolas sarkozy sur la
loi ogm on en parlait hier les députés
ump ont voulu serrer les coudes
ils ont réservé une ovation à jean
françois copé et à françois fillon
mais le malaise persiste notamment du
côté des élus restés fidèles à dominique
de villepin
thierry curtet christophe quincke
messieurs président alors que jean
françois copé prend la parole dans
l'hémicycle cet après midi les députés
de la majorité se lève pour l'applaudir
2000 l'image est bien sûr calculer il
faut afficher l'unité retrouvée
après l'incroyable bévue de la veille
c'est d'ailleurs le premier ministre qui
lui répond incidents regrettables d'hier
ne détournera pas le gouvernement et sa
majorité de leurs responsabilités cette
mairie l'opposition elle se gausse de
cet affichage
car dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
rien n'a changé
de nombreux députés
d'où toujours du projet de loi ogm je ne
suis pas contre les ogm
ceci dit je pense que là il ya un réel
risque de contamination des cultures ogm
sur des cultures classiques ou
biologiques ou autre s'il s'interroge
d'autres seront inamovible dans leurs
bottes françois grosdidier s'opposera
aux textes et refuse de politiser le
débat
malgré les pressions je voterai contre
et je pense qu'un certain nombre de
collègues aussi comme en première
lecture
déjà le premier ministre nous avait
demandé de voter non pas pour le texte
mais pour le contexte en dramatisant un
politisant dangereux je crois que c'est
un tort et la grogne des députés ump
pourrait bien durer car les réformes sur
les institutions et l'économie qui
arrive ne font pas l'unanimité de la
majorité loin de là et au delà du couac
politique il y a le texte lui-même
pourquoi cette loi ogm ne satisfait
vraiment personne ni les pros ni les
anti ogm explications edouard baer jean
thierry breton que prévoit la loi ogm le
texte garantit la liberté de consommer
et de produire avec des ogm mais protège
aussi les cultures bio conventionnelles
et à ostie problème pour l'heure en
attendant l'avis des scientifiques aucun
seuil défini ce qu'est le sans ogm
le projet de loi renvoie au seuil
européen un produit et étiquetés ogm
quand il en contient 0 9% on est loin du
seuil souhaité par les écologistes
la loi prévoit aussi plus de
transparence à la parcelle près on
pourra savoir où sont cultivées des
plantes transgéniques en consultant un
registre national sur internet contre
partie de la transparence
le fauchage de gm sera un délit puni au
maximum par deux ans de prison et 75000
euros damende simon après le grenelle de
l'environnement
ce texte fait pourtant beaucoup de
mécontents certains agriculteurs froid
ogm refuse la notion même de
responsabilité si la notion de
responsabilité qu'encourent les
producteurs même si l'on respecté toutes
les règles de production
en face les anti ogm sont aussi critique
envers la loi
nous nous demandons que justement ce
soit les semenciers qui assume ses
responsabilités parce qu'après tout
c'est eux qui met sur le marché un
produit dont on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
garantir la totale innocuité puisque
même aucune compagnie d'assurance au
monde
n'accepte de couvrir ce risque pour
l'heure le texte de loi ne satisfait ni
les pros ni des anti ogm
tous demandent au gouvernement de revoir
sa copie on en vient maintenant à cette
grève qui s'annonce suivi chez les
fonctionnaires demain et notamment dans
l'éducation alors s'agit-il d'une énième
journée d'action comme on en a connu
beaucoup ou bien faut-il s'attendre à un
mouvement profond et peut-être durable
on va s'y arrêter un instant d'abord la
sphère dans la sphère demain sera mise
en place pour la seconde fois le fameux
service minimum d'accueil pour les
élèves du primaire
ils y allaient pour et les contre hélène
vergne bonjour ici marc rostan
d'outre-mer ce message téléphonique sera
diffusée à tous les parents d'élèves à
alès dans le gard le service minimum
s'expérimente demain pour la troisième
fois dans cette municipalité ump on ne
parle pas de bataille politique gauche
droite mais de services rendus à la
population
ce service public où l'on songe l'homme
on n'est pas des casseurs de grève
puisque gens continuent à faire la grève
les gens qui sont solidaires ne voient
pas leurs gorges pas en disant je suis
jamais intéressé d'autres changent et
qu'il faut pas aller au delà de la
démarche 70 classes sur les 130 que
compte la ville devrait être fermée
demain en remplacement des enseignants
grévistes des agents municipaux
habituellement au contact des enfants
les parents eux sont satisfaits
j'ai la chance d'avoir une ville si vous
les quilles qui me proposent ce service
et c'est reparti je me mets à la place
des parents qui sont seuls qui peuvent
pas se payer une nourrice et qui ont
besoin que leurs enfants soient à
l'école pour pouvoir aller travailler
pour d'autres il s'agit d'une atteinte
au droit de grève
moi je suis content de la grèce très
moyen
d'action et que s'il faut me prit un
minimum bien ça dérange pas les gens et
donc non je suis contre et à montpellier
ville socialiste le maire n'a pas hésité
un instant le service minimum ne sera
pas expérimenter la ville de montpellier
tout à fait solidaire de non seulement
des agents de l'éducation nationale mais
aussi solidaire de ces de ses propres
agents donc ceux qui voudront travailler
travailleront ce qu'ils voudront pas
travailler ne travailleront pas et donc
la ville n'assumera pas bien évidemment
les fonctions des agents de l'éducation
nationale aux familles dont de se
débrouiller demain dans 40% des écoles
elles trouveront porte close en voyons
maintenant quelles sont les raisons de
ce conflit dans la fonction publique et
notamment à l'école et il s'agit
principalement des effectifs
aurélia bros les suppressions de postes
c'est la question qui divise pour les
lycéens comme pour les enseignants ça ne
passe pas à la rentrée prochaine
onze mille deux cents postes seront
supprimés parmi lesquels 8830
enseignants des collèges et lycées
publics
ce n'est qu'une étape les coûts
devraient continuer en 2009
les syndicats parlent d'une hémorragie
le secondaire va pourtant perdre 40
mille élèves l'an prochain même si le
primaire lui est en hausse
pour xavier darcos la france aurait en
plus trop de professeurs pour un
résultat pas à la hauteur côté maternel
et primaire c'est le nouveau programme
scolaire qui coince les enseignants y
voient un recul pédagogique
ce programme serait en plus selon eux
inapplicable le nombre d'heures de cours
ayant diminué avec la suppression du
samedi matin
les syndicats craignent un apprentissage
plus superficielle alors que 15% des
élèves qui entrent en 6e sont en grave
difficulté et je vous le disais le ton
monte deux fédérations de parents
d'élèves la peep et l'appel national
proteste contre les conséquences de ce
conflit elle estime je cite que les
enfants sont instrumentalisés qu'ils
sont en danger lors des manifestations
et que le troisième trimestre est
tronquée voici maintenant le point de
vue d'un enseignant il a 28 ans il est
professeur d'économie dans un lycée du
val-de-marne et il fera grève
demain nabila taboury didier d'art en
trois mois de contestation dans ce lycée
de vitry-sur-seine et pas un jour sans
que xavier pas l'art et ses collègues ne
se mobilise vous aviez n'en est pas à
son premier mouvement de grève
mais avec cette suppression de poste
dans un établissement classé sensible
la pilule a du mal à passer je suis très
attaché maintenant au lycée jean macé
j'ai vraiment pas envie de partir et de
quitter ce qui c est pour ça je
m'investis énormément dans la dans la
lutte contre la suppression des postes
xavier à 28 ans arrivée des deux sèvres
il y a 6 ans une enseigne l'économie et
la gestion
pour lui les conditions d'enseignement
vont se dégrader car pour compenser les
suppressions de postes les profs devront
faire des heures supplémentaires du
sport dans mon cas à peu près 100 élèves
ou 120 élèves à gérer si on me rajoute
encore 30
voilà il ya plus du tout de suivi
individuel de l'élève et là on perd
vraiment la qualité d'enseignement des
heures supplémentaires c'est aussi le
risque d'enseigner dans plusieurs lycées
des champions à des temps de transport d
emploi disant qu'ils sont pas forcément
compatibles des transports ça veut dire
qu'on va arriver à redon st-ours que
l'on sera pas qu'on sera encore sur un
problème qu'on a peut-être dans l'autre
les c'est qu'on appelle le temps de
régler xavier est professeur certifié 18
heures d'enseignement par semaine
autant à préparer ses cours et corriger
les copies pour 2000 euros net par mois
toujours dans l'actualité sociale noté
le si vous devez voyager quatre
syndicats d'air france appellent tous
les salariés à s'associer à la grève de
24 heures le 22 mai donc jeudi de la
semaine prochaine pour les retraites le
syndicat autonome de la sncf l'afp
jacques appelle lui aussi à cesser le
travail la santé vous vous souvenez sans
doute de cette jeune femme anorexique
qui avait fait polémique en septembre
dernier en posant nue pour une campagne
contre la maladie en italie elle est
française s'appelle isabelle caro est ce
geste a peut-être servi de déclic
aujourd'hui elle dit aller un peu mieux
elle s'est lancé dans le théâtre et elle
vient de publier un livre avec un
objectif témoigner pour prévenir des
dangers de l'anorexie c'est le dossier
de cette édition il est signé laetitia
legendre trousses stéphane guillemot et
vincent barral et voilà
dir longtemps elle n'a été que l'ombre
d'elle-même aujourd'hui isabelle caro
aime croire que les choses ont changé
notamment grâce à des leçons de théâtre
au cours florent
mais non alors une sorte de thérapie
concept comédienne qui met à profit ses
souffrances pour lutter contre
l'anorexie
je n'y pense pas je n'y passe pas quand
je suis sur scène monsieur j'ai c'est de
justement de de revivre
c'est pas des personnages de malades que
je joue c'est pas des personnes sondées
personnage que j'aime et les personnages
que j'ai envie durée et pourtant en
septembre dernier c'est bien son propre
rôle qu'elle tient sous le feu des
projecteurs en italie cette campagne de
publicité suscite la polémique
un corps nu décharné d'un mètre soixante
cinq pour 30 kilos qu'on expose un
message ambigu censé détourner les
jeunes de la tentation de la maigreur
c'est un corps de vieilles enfin c'est
un corbeau vieille dame a alors confié
pas la regarder
aujourd'hui isabelle caro se raconte
dans un livre sa volonté de ne pas
grandir une mère possessive une enfance
difficile
l'anorexie lui a volé la moitié de sa
vie avec son lot de cohmad
hospitalisations à répétition les
cheveux les dents qui tombe et le
quotidien qui devient progressivement
souffrance entraînait même comprendre la
louche le matin de vue
du lit à la douche caraman et je rampais
je pouvais pas je pouvais pas bouger les
jeunes
j'étais cuit
des mortes près j'ai été très longue à
réaliser à quel point c'est dangereux et
ça m'avait dit ce jour là la jeune femme
est invitée à sensibiliser des candidats
au mannequinat sur les dangers de la
maigreur à tout prix c'est que vous en
sentez pas bien aller voir un médecin
n'hésitez pas à en parler surtout par
les ans moi j'ai trop attendu quelques
temps moi c'était à 25 kg d'un côté ça
me fait un peu peur je ne voudrais pas
tomber mais pas question pour d'isabelle
caro de servir d'alibi elle se défend de
faire l'apologie de sa maladie sans
oublier son propre intérêt en tant
qu'amoureux justement même si je suis là
pour aider être comme là pour justement
essayer de penser à autre chose
aujourd'hui 30 à 40000 personnes
essentiellement de jeunes femmes
souffriraient en france d'anorexie et
même si la guérison est loin d'être
acquise
isabelle caro affirme avoir retrouvé ces
derniers mois là soit de vivre le livre
est intitulé la petite fille qui ne
voulait pas grossir
il est publié chez flammarion
l'actualité judiciaire avec l'ouverture
aujourd'hui du procès d'un récidiviste
pour le viol et le meurtre d'une
étudiante de 24 ans qui habitait la
résidence dont il était le gardien
ce qui retient l'attention dans cette
audience c'est que l'homme avait déjà
été condamné deux fois libéré deux fois
et qu'il était repassé à l'acte à chaque
fois vincent fichman thomas donzel
3on qu'elles attendent ce moment de la
justice
la mère et la soeur de la victime exige
des réponses jean-luc ier avait déjà été
condamné deux fois pour viols
comment at il pu violer à nouveau puis
tué audrey jouannet sans que personne ne
puisse rien faire
en salle d'audience la peine de mort non
je ne sais pas pour la peine de mort je
vais pas aller jusque là mais
ma fille est morte et ma fille elle en a
pris perpétuité ne ressentira plus
jamais de son trouble
en 2002 après deux précédentes
condamnations
jean-luc kayes trouve un emploi de
gardien d'immeuble en banlieue
parisienne
à l'époque la loi ne prévoit pas de
suivi pour les délinquants sexuels
en 2005 il sait qu'il est roux dre
johanne et sa jeune voisine de 24 ans la
viole puis là tu en 1990 l'expert dit il
récidivera donc nous le savions tout le
monde le savait on a laissé cet individu
dans la nature on ne s'est pas inquiété
de savoir ce qu'il allait faire
et aujourd'hui on en paye le prix devant
les jurés jean luc ayé évoque ses
pulsions sexuelles
quand le président lui demande pourquoi
il répond ce qui se passe dans ma tête
j'aimerais bien le savoir les experts
demain tenteront d'expliquer comment
celui que certains décrivait comme
serviable a basculé dans l'horreur
jean lucas yeahs encourt la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
l'inflation n'augmente plus mais reste à
un niveau élevé 0 3% au mois d'avril 3%
sur un an les produits frais sont
particulièrement mises en cause
démonstration par l'exemple ce soir avec
l'envolée du prix de la fraise la fraise
française la garrigue est réputée l'une
des meilleures de 2007 à 2008 en un an
seulement le prix a augmenté en moyenne
de 14,6 pour cent
pourquoi explication caroline thébaux
emmanuel bec avec notre bureau à
toulouse jusqu'à 5 euros 70 la barquette
de garrigue est une addition de plus en
plus allé depuis plusieurs années c'est
un produit
donc moi je considère que c'est beaucoup
plus cher qu'il ya quelques années
un sentiment confirmé par les
statistiques l'année dernière le kilo de
gariguettes se vendait en moyenne 9
euros 47
aujourd'hui il est à 10 euros 85 soit
plus de 14 % d'augmentation
première explication un mauvais mois
d'avril
ici dans le sud-ouest premier lieu de
production du coup cet agriculteur a
augmenté ses prix il ya une légère
augmentation saison mais très légère
quand je parle c'est pour ça que ce qui
veut dire que c'est pas énorme
je dirais mais après on n'a aucune
maîtrise sur tout le parcours jusqu'aux
consommateurs vivant sa barquette un
euro 10 vient ensuite l'expéditeur qui
se charge du transport ils sont
kilomètres plus loin quand elle arrive à
rungis la barquette coûte environ 1 euro
ce grossiste va rajouter 20 centimes 50
du mas dieu pour lui c'est surtout la
forte consommation qui fait grimper le
prix
la semaine dernière on avait un temps
été très bons en région parisienne un
temps - bouche les lieux de production
donc manque de marchandises ici nous
dragonne une très bonne demande et c'est
ce qui fait que play et elle faisait
lever toute la semaine
après négociations les vendeurs de
fruits va donc acheter la barquette 1
euro 50 pour la revendre au marché 2
euros 50
bienheureux différence entre ici et le
marché passé ma marge en moins et les
longs faux frais les employés
charge du camp selon la profession les
prix devraient bientôt baisser avec
l'arrivée des prochaines récoltes à
l'étranger comme prévu hillary clinton
l'a emporté très largement dans la
primaire démocrate de virginie
occidentale aux états unis 67 % contre
26 pour son adversaire barack obama avec
la peine ces campagnes là bas pas de
quoi bouleverser l'arithmétique en tout
cas le sénateur et ce largement en tête
au nombre des délégués
george bush lui est arrivé aujourd'hui
en israël pour assister aux célébrations
du 60e anniversaire de la fondation de
l'état hébreu
il a loué l' alliance avec israël contre
je cite les terroristes et les tyrans à
l'occasion de cet anniversaire voici un
autre visage sans doute moins connus du
pays si la ville de tel aviv est devenue
une des capitales de la fête
elle est réputée pour ses bars et boîtes
de nuit sa vie dorée bien loin des
tensions qu'on imagine sur place renault
bernard mossi art mode
un air de californie qui ferait presque
oublier que le pays est en crise ici
malgré le danger
pas question de se priver de plaisir
pour ces trentenaires tel aviv c'est la
dolce vita et la guerre avec les
palestiniens il refuse d'y penser aux
personnes qui vivent ici ils envie de
vivre au jour le jour et chaque instant
quand on est à tel-aviv et qu'à 18 ans
on nous dit d'aller faire l'armée ça
donne pas envie c'est évident la
violence tel aviv connaît 75 morts en
huit ans malgré quatre attentats contre
des bars et des discothèques la vie
nocturne reste frénétique loin de
jérusalem la religieuse ici pas de
contrainte pas de tabou après la plage
ruben et ses amis passent par un pick up
bar le concept est unique dans le monde
en y entrant célibataire et en quelques
minutes on en recevra compagne et aller
vite pour oublier
très bien les gens comme ça entre très
très facilement ça permet de en fait
sauf est un petit peu on appelle ça la
bulle tel aviv une enclave où les jeunes
se protègent de la violence qui les
entourent du conflit israélo-palestinien
qui n'en finit pas mais cette
nonchalance cache un mal plus profond
ce syndrome est bien connu de cette scic
analystes les jeunes constituent 90 % de
sa clientèle
c'est une lutte contre la dépression et
qui peuvent faire la fête et une lutte
contre l' des patients mais la faire
systématiquement et avoir besoin de la
faire tout le temps avoir une espèce de
duck est renouvelée de fait c'est bien
entendu se défendre contre la négation
quand il ne fait pas la fête ruben et
avocat d'affaires
son bureau c'est une terrasse de café
c'est là qu'il prépare son prochain
dossier ruben a quitté la france il ya
dix ans si si l'avenir n'est pas garanti
pas question de partir pour autant le
plus important c'est d'être des
transferts
d'être là de vivre ici au quotidien et
pour moi c'est une façon aussi de
montrer que c'est un pays que j'aime
quand ils ont fondé israël
les pionniers était loin d'imaginer que
soixante ans plus tard même les plus
turbulents que leurs enfants seraient
autant attachés à leur terre en bref
encore à l'étranger un attentat en
espagne une fourgonnette piégée visant
une caserne de la garde civile au pays
basque a fait un mort et quatre blessés
attentat attribué à letea commentaires
du chef du gouvernement josé luis
zapatero
la démocratie s'imposera contre la
terreur la liberté vaincra le fanatisme
assassin fin de citation une visite en
france
relativement discrète mais jugée
importante pour le sort d'ingrid
betancourt celle du président équatorien
rafael correa paris compte sur lui pour
renouer le contact avec les farc
dorothée olliéric franck brisset rafael
correa sait que la libération d'ingrid
betancourt est l'une des priorités de
son homologue français le président
équatorien a donc affirmé qu'il
redoublerait d'efforts pour obtenir la
libération des otages
si la france a besoin de la médiation et
des territoires de l'équateur pour
libérer les otages
on serait le président équatorien qui
n'a pas de nouvelles directes de l'otage
franco colombienne a tenu à rencontrer
les proches d'ingrid betancourt pour les
assurer de son soutien pour la famille
d'ingrid c'est un nouveau pas en avant
il nous a dit que les contacts avec les
farc avaient été rompues après le
bombardement d'un campement mais qu'il y
avait une légère reprise de contact qui
allait être approfondies dans les jours
à venir
la tête du camp des farc par l'armée
colombienne sur le territoire équatorien
voisins c'était le 1er mars dernier la
mort du numéro deux de la guérilla raul
reyes avait mis fin aux espoirs d'une
libération rapide d'ingrid betancourt et
déclenché une crise diplomatique entre
l'équateur et la colombie
il ne faut rien attendre du gouvernement
colombien parce qu'il n'a pas la volonté
politique et de libérer les autres d la
solution est politique
quand les farc arrêteront les
enlèvements les attentats pour ce qui
est contre les droits de l'homme
alors on pourra les retirer de la liste
des organisations terroristes selon le
président équatorien ingrid betancourt
aurait dû recouvrer la liberté ya deux
mois aujourd'hui sans contact direct
avec les farc plus personne n'ose
avancer une date pour sa libération
une image de l'etna le volcan le plus
actif d'europe en sicile est à nouveau
entré en éruption après les alertes de
ce week-end à des bouches se sont
ouvertes sur un flanc du cratère
débouche par lesquels ces chats plage
pour l'heure les habitations ne sont pas
menacés effrayant et fascinant à la fois
celui qu'on appelle l'homme à réaction a
réussi un premier vol avec sa nouvelle
aile de carbone fixée sur son dos largué
par un avion et la planète pendant cinq
minutes
équipé de quatre mini réacteurs dans son
dos à bex en suisse nicolas chateauneuf
pascal c'est l'état
cela ressemble à un minuscule avions à
réaction de près les yeux s'écarquillent
soul elle il y à un homme un hérité
d'icare qui volent à 300 kilomètres
heures 6 minutes de haute voltige et
d'adrénaline pour le suisse yves rossy
avant de retrouver à terre les amis les
journalistes et de refaire son vol dans
sa tête avec cette phase si délicat du
largage de l'avion à 2500 mètres
d'altitude
dans une position de piqué et déployer
les ailes au bon moment parce il y
déploie comme ça cependant brille comme
c'est vraiment un truc c'est là la
partie compliquée à partir du moment où
les ailes sont déployés et chiots piqué
avec ses ailes j'ai plus qu'à mettre les
gaz et là c'est du bonheur trente ans
d'expérience en aéronautique cinq ans de
recherches pour le pilote de ligne ce
vol est un accomplissement la précédente
elles s'étaient crashés alors il l'a
reconstruite amélioré avec son équipe il
faut penser aux moindres détails et même
à la combinaison ignifugée qu'en jeu
pour perdre les poils du scion la
protège un peu l'histoire ça sort quand
même les garde à 7 800 degrés il ya des
protections keibler par balles si la une
des turbines venait à exploser
comme j'ai mes petites fesses pas loin
de six turbines on a mis une protection
par voire carrément en vol yves rossy
pilotes sans instrument le moindre aux
mouvements de son corps modifie les
directions de l'ale c'est du vol pur
quoi il y a qu'à penser à qu'un jeu
allait l'attaquer et ocz donné ça tourne
c'est presque du roi une sorte d'état
second set elle est le fruit de cinq ans
de recherches intensives ses concepteurs
espèrent bien faire baisser ces coûts
fabrication mais ceux qui rêvent
d'arriver au bureau en aile volante
devront attendre encore un petit peu et
surtout s'entraîner très sérieusement
voilà et prochain défi pour yves rossy
nous dit nicolas chateauneuf une
traversée de la manche le coup d'envoi
du festival de cannes la première montée
des marches pour sean penn et les autres
membres du jury
dans un instant nous retrouvons nos deux
invités angelina jolie dustin hoffman
réunis dans un dessin animé dont ils
assurent les voix c'est assez inhabituel
d'abord les images de cette soirée
christophe airaud nadine picard il y fit
que ce soit de s'embrasser sur les
marches de cannes car la croisette ou
moins deux mais c'est toujours le centre
du monde un monde aux couleurs
américaines les son défilé dennis hopper
eva longoria et fac de nous
puis surgit un jury il est mené par sean
penn un jury qui s'est déclarée à les
coupes du monde robel est sûrement en
cadence
alors dans la salle un peu de musique il
est invité par sean penn c'est richie
havens il ouvre à houston
rhinau
mais c'est claude lanzmann le
réalisateur de shoah qui déclare la
compétition ouverte je déclare ouverte
durant cette quinzaine de cinéma on
attend wenders tarantino spielberg silga
rallye fait mais demain c'est au
lendemain qui fera la star sèche
répandent a acquis shifu et tigresse les
joies de dustin hoffman et angelina
jolie lui enseigne les principes du
conflit pour sauver sa peau et ils sont
avec nous en duplex de cannes angelina
jolie et dustin hoffman bonsoir à vous
deux et merci d'être avec nous c'est un
couple un duo assez inattendue est ce
que vous vous connaissez l'un l'autre
angelina jolie
on n'a pas passé beaucoup de temps
ensemble mais nous ne connaissons est ce
que vous aviez déjà tourné ensemble
travailler ensemble dustin hoffman non
nous reste encore tourné ensemble nous
sommes ensemble dans ce film mais nous
n'avons pas partagé de scènes ensemble
si vous voulez oui bien sûr ça se fait
séparément tourner un dessin animé
doublé des personnages est ce qu on le
fait parce que c'est amusant
est-ce qu on le fait parce qu'on pense à
ses propres enfants ou petits-enfants ou
est ce qu on le fait parce que c'est
bien payé que c'est tellement amusant et
c'est génial de pouvoir faire quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de faire
j'imagine personne refusant de jouer un
personnage extraordinaire dans un film
d'animation dans un film que vos enfants
est gros et les petits enfants aimeront
et avec lequel on s'amuse beaucoup donc
ya pas de raison de ne pas le faire
alors demain vous allez monter les
marches le film sera présenté hors
concours mais il sera présenté
dustin hoffman est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui donne le trac est ce que c'est
important ou est-ce que c'est simplement
un divertissement de monter les marches
à cannes
non j'ai vraiment le trac parce que je
n'ai jamais travaillé dans ce genre de
d'animation et maintenant que je les
fais j'ai perdu tout mon animation
naturel comme vous pouvez le voir donc
sur le tapis rouge je suis dans un état
catatonique or vois que vous avez gardé
beaucoup d'autres animations et que ça
fait beaucoup rire angelina jolie depuis
mariage avec brad pitt angelina jolie
est ce que qu'est-ce que ça fait en fait
d'être suivi et pied vous êtes une des
grandes stars mondiales est ce que c'est
une grande gêne d'être à ce point
traqué en quelque sorte par les
photographes ailleurs fait je passe mon
temps à la maison je passais mes
journées à la maison avec la famille
c'est 95% de ma vie et c'est très rare
qu'on sorte pour venir à des événements
comme celui-ci on laisse les paparazzi
devenir une partie de notre vie on
essaie d'être avec les enfants s'amuser
avec les enfants on se concentre là
dessus
alors je vais vous poser une question de
paparazzi on m'a soufflé à l'oreillette
que vous attendait des jumeaux
est ce la vérité oui oui oui
et bien voilà une information sur france
2 toutes nos félicitations de zilina
joli tout ça on sait que vous avez
habité paris vous habitez vous avez
habité saint jean cap ferrat en ce
moment même qu'est ce qui vous lie
particulièrement la france c'est un pays
merveilleux que j'aime beaucoup mais
nous voulons aussi que nos enfants
apprennent une deuxième langue et qu'ils
sachent ce que c'est d'être américains
mais aussi européens et d'être proche
d'autres parties du monde
et la france est une bonne base pour ça
et la langue est merveilleuse notre fils
apprend le français et je pense que les
autres la prendront aussi par la suite
donc c'est merveilleux pour nous d'avoir
d'autres familles ici dernière question
pour dustin hoffman sais que vous êtes
très populaire en france depuis vos
premiers films dans les années 70
macadam cowboy ou little big man est ce
que vous comptez tourner encore
longtemps très longtemps au cinéma j'ai
une chose à dire puisque c'est la
dernière question est ce que j'ai le
droit
allez-y c'est un plaisir d'abord je
souhaiterais félicité angélina jolie
parce que ça fait très longtemps que je
fais ce métier et je ne connais personne
qui sache trouver un si bon équilibre
entre son engagement vis à vis la
famille le travail humanitaire le
travail tout à fait extraordinaire
qu'elle fait par ailleurs je voulais
simplement lui dire c'est merci beaucoup
de si nos fans et puis votre message
angelina jolie est passé merci beaucoup
aux thèmes qu'elle choisit brad pitt est
pas moi
voilà voilà la conversation s'est
poursuivie quelques instants après un
entretien enregistré quelques minutes
avant ce journal tout à l'heure en
duplex de cannes une information de
sport pour terminer qui a pris beaucoup
de monde par surprise justine henin
numéro un mondiale du tennis féminin
annonce qu'elle met fin à sa carrière à
25 ans seulement pour cause de défaut de
motivation on l'écouté alors voilà c'est
une page qui se tourne aujourd'hui je ne
ressens pas de tristesse au contraire
c'est plutôt une délivrance plutôt un
soulagement
plutôt un regard vers l'avenir et je
cherche toujours à me construire
autrement qu'à travers le tennis
quoique ça m'a apporté beaucoup de
belles choses mais c'est une façon de
revenir à l'essentiel aussi
voilà avant de refermer ce journal je
vous en rappelle l'un des principaux
titres
des villes entières raser un bilan de 50
à 80 mille morts et disparus ce soir la
chine revoit à la hausse les
conséquences du séisme
cent mille soldats et policiers sont
déployés sur les lieux
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
tania young
20h50 louis page à demain
nous non
que l'info en continu c'est aussi sur
france 2 point fr